we're gonna zoom in town a lot of things
I came in front of Paris and a meeting
also children disorder yes you're going
to crease oh oh wait mrs. Blum ha ha
Oh touch a boob I love it he's really
getting focused right unlike the whole
like facial facial yeah I know he's been
painting like something crazy
that's awesome very cool and so how long
have you guys been working together
awesome
how does it all start for you yep
already doing before I am cool yep
and yeah I start immediately four years
ago since where yeah nothing around the
first fitness you do is you're going to
kind of like get it going no more yeah
so I mean it kind of blew up at a rapid
pace okay you all know I love it so
happen what's is like always my kind of
first instinct is there anything
actually I have contacts from life's I
know you have some context is there any
potentially I could help you guys with
and things stand out anything as you
guys are navigating through this that I
could be a helper to be very honest I'm
not sure right like I mean I feel like
growing is something that you guys have
done a very good job with right like I
you need get here by accident
I think the bigger question you know I
think a lot of times when I spend time
with people that are making a lot of
money or like it's going well the
question becomes what's the strategy
right like and by the way that doesn't
need to be one like I'm not so convinced
that you can't go on living forever
appearance these brand deals and being
crazy
I don't know right like I've seen this
happen so many times right being the
first result on Google and the best AOL
accounts like [ __ ] changes so I think
the question becomes like how are you go
I think you guys have seen things come
and go I mean I don't think Instagram
influences going away
Morrow I do think that it's going to get
police in a different way by Instagram
but I think I think in general no I
think what so for example I don't have
the most followers I just think that I'm
good at business and like where things
go and so I guess the question comes has
there been any big thing you've been
thinking about I think a lot of people
make the mistake of like we're going to
do television now or this and that or
just think about building brands behind
it or are you looking to sign you know
somebody if they're smart consign a 10
million dollar deal with a core brand
like I guess that you I'm friendly with
the former CEO which one we Watchers
like like you know I'm running with the
CEO of Equinox like I guess the question
comes you know since we're here yeah I
know better than the MNH yeah I mean I
think the biggest thing is because I was
kind of like the first at base and so
I'm like the trendsetter
of the fitness female you know muscles
are like now more acceptable like type
of thing so I think the amazing is like
usually in some jarrah or space there's
like some of these kind of look up -
right well this person's done it so it
kind of paved the way but I bet they're
paving the way for people does that make
sense so it kind of it it is kind of
like I don't know I'm like blindfolded
like kind of like going in this you know
I need to so quickly you don't want very
kind of like which is why Nick that's
the front which is why the question more
is like about you and your life and like
your ambitions and wants and dreams and
hopes and more so they're like Oh
karynda's a soul all right but you to
feel of that or you just kind of like in
the vortex right now it's like so insane
and exciting and awesome that you're
like holy [ __ ] I can't believe this is
actually happening
I mean yeah yeah make my way up like
literally every single time I take a
selfie every single day which is a lot
of time today how many times I cannot
believe this bucket so like I'm with I'm
with you and let another year ago I was
like yeah hundred all with my entire
photo
Oh anything from your perspective for me
right so I just like day-to-day kind of
like working with friends my breast job
was I'm kind of going back and forth
with them yes I really have to educate
them or 100% open pages right what she
really does is really different from all
the other girls out there right and I'm
just commoditizing the math right they
look at the followers or likes
engagement and there's no brand but
that's a place right right like I get
paid a lot of money to publicly speak on
the brand more so than the actual mass
of my life yeah I never want to
commoditize there's a lot of pretty
girls with a lot of followers and even
if you may have when you have a whole
lot still three of them can get to that
same number the cost less for free
they'll quit you know messing people are
thinking about right so that's that's
why you just start getting really
serious about brand position and then
essentially we're now that part were
very kind of like taking keep
conversations of brand very quietly
kind of money for us right right a
thought longevity keep ear elevated
right but the long-term goal in today's
really not yeah and I think the right
strategy for you guys just to think
about like look where does leaving I
have a million dollar man action figure
here when he was a wrestler in the 80s
he said everybody's got a price I think
it's important for you to price in a way
that speaks again your strategy here's
what I mean you think selective
experience I'm a funny feeling you're
going to spend a lot of times trying to
justify why you like XYZ brand if they
offered you a million dollars for one
post
so what I'm saying there is you should
come up with a spicing strategy of
what's the number that gets you to start
the bathing and you should actually
price that way because then you have all
the leverage yeah got it so that would
be like a pricing strategy so pearance
you got paid to appear somewhere how
much of that do you want to do or not
one of you every day
that's all fine like meet people in
person I'm sure they'd love that too
yeah I think we might even think
actually to do how much of that are you
doing oh you what's what's up with your
website is it just when you land on your
website does it speak to all the things
that you want to be doing right away
above the fold in or above the fold both
well I mean website where when you learn
done it really know like what pet it has
to be done what she offers off the
website right away right um it doesn't
mean she loves what he does off her
website is like the core core business
at the end of the day right and it also
would hurt would be big people a person
that's the first thing that they bring
about the right they got hurt on your
back right I mean I get into public
speaking you know with them I have you
know I got a random behind the stories
ridiculous I got a random email the
person's like you want to speak I was
again I like super pumped and I thought
as I pay for my own plane tickets in
2009 eight and then he's like how much
he charged Nicole [ __ ] how much I'll
charge and I try to come up with a crazy
big number I said five thousand dollars
she said okay like vodka because it's
more and I just going to me pretend I
only heard thirty minutes when I knew
was an hour and I got $10,000 because I
wait a minute yeah and he says okay on a
bike [ __ ] there's more money in this I'm
not I did it and I have no idea what
would happen Italy no idea right and I
know and when I tell you I loved it
there is no place on earth where I feel
better so what I would tell you is if
that's a place where you're thinking and
it is very lucrative and very smart to
do don't ever ever as awesome as it's
going don't ever ever waver from being
strategically humbled
I would speak pricks is that something
you want to do at the right event yeah
that's the right people yeah I do not
because like obviously when I started
and of course you know it and by the way
it's always the same game even as you
get you know yeah of course
this is new space you know I like to get
in there and people I think the biggest
things you guys have to figure out and
should spend all your time on surgically
is how not to get pigeonholed has pretty
girl with a lot of powers because that
is a real challenge to the problem at
all
yes you do I'll tell you why because
you're a pretty girl with a lot of
powers like it's like you're right about
your core I'm worried about this town
where there's where there's real money
usually was the last being posted right
all right it's like kind of a little
moving we first started together like
we're kind of like talking about it
they're kind of like how are you gonna
be different for life have you have you
two minutes have you broken the glass
ceiling and talked to the audience as
the business woman that you are yet I
think he should I'll tell you why I get
why you won't get as much engagement and
like I'm very aware of why a lot of your
fans are looking for other kind of
content I would 100% do it it will
change a lot for you like even the way
you just answered me I mean I know you
for nothing for four seconds even the
way you just answered me about the free
thing just the way you did it makes me
optimistic that you should very much
focus on it
[Laughter]
I just I'm just I'm good at pattern
recognition I just I'm good at what I do
like if you actually have the chops you
need to show that and like people care
about dumb [ __ ] like oh but if I do that
I think it as many likes or engagement
because what they want is this kind of
photo I'm like cool that means you're
worried about the micro instead of the
macro while 23 percent of that audience
and be like holy [ __ ] yes and start
looking up to you in a different way by
the way both guys and girls I think you
should totally very what I think is like
really serious by hiatal people right we
got to break that just not for me
other girls she had ever employees as
routine like we didn't explain that I'm
like this one well that's exactly what I
would find that it's not being smart
like even like art picture together
right now in your account ecologically
whoa why should over here it means like
people know that I'm not like hanging
out with the pretty girls I'm into it
like that's the important [ __ ] like to
me that was very reactionary to me like
oh they're being smart like it made me
want to do this right I'm like there's
thinking smart look we don't a lot of
times what do you live that like right
like you know at some point let's you
can email me let me first follow up in
this life like I'm a little bit behind
right now I have to get to sports
snapchat or meeting like but I would
love to like talk to you guys a little
bit more about what I was pushing which
is your right to the people that are
deeply deeply paying attention maybe you
don't look that part but to every media
player here you look that part and all
the time to look right so what they're
going to do if they even get down that
rabbit hole is look at those 15 posts or
read that Business Insider article or
like [ __ ] when a who will you see that
you're on this business podcast and it
does have to be business that we're
going down one path I don't know enough
of value I just need to get to know you
like got it it says what you've got to
show different looks in different places
and in your main place which yes well I
could even see a bunch of like scum
bucket
because I fell wait a minute like one
out of every four times I don't care of
course you don't yet the end what we're
kind of looking for kind of you because
of that very much yep do you think um
when she grows a trench few more towards
you I honestly I think that she should
do whatever the [ __ ] she wants and then
she'll dominate I'm worried that she's
overthinking and holding back certain
[ __ ] that she wants one that I promise I
think that she's holding back a thing or
two because she's smart and she
understands what the audience wants so
it's not that I want her to do something
it's that I want her to do what she
actually want I'm doing got it to set a
little thing there right like I don't
think every woman should be about
empowering other women if that's what
they love then they should do that like
she might love sports she might like
cuisine like I think she just needs to
be her because that would create so many
more avenues and that's what that's what
the cliche move that people with your
size influence and your genre and your
look aren't doing enough out which is
why they're getting commoditized it's
why I tell them you need people and meme
accounts if you are making [ __ ]
videos with white tops and learning you
just come on if I know you what you
counted is they're all the [ __ ] same
shot it like filming you with three
people for a minute in some sort of
business setting or casual setting more
of you the reality TV stars are doing
the most have a lot of looks that sure
would not work if it was the same scene
over and over yeah got it
like there's a lot people like like
there's a clearly a lot potentially for
you to share so it's more of that right
like your version is what I think people
are making mistakes up which is they're
picking a platform that's trendy and
they're going with it and they're
winning in the short term enrollees in
the long term right I just want to know
every aspect about her and I want that
in play it's why I'm winning the most
visa I don't care about anything other
than like
I'm gonna sit like for whatever you've
seen I mean you're like this is the same
[ __ ] you've been saying right like this
is it like I don't know overthink it I
don't want to play I don't need million
dollar man I love these heavy you ask me
I want to be like who I actually am it
gets easy better and it gets better and
people [ __ ] taste it and don't front
that you're an amazing entrepreneur if
you're not maybe it's the documentation
of the journey of becoming a better
entrepreneur that's [ __ ] inspiring
this let me give you a let me finish
that pep talk off because if you're
really gonna understand one another say
the amount of people that I know from my
space early YouTube and Twitter that
looked exactly like you I'm going to
look exactly like you but look the part
winning a lot of followers that took it
for granted and now would like break the
vine stars that I'm fed into it that
took it for granted
it can change quickly so complacency is
the death of where you're at right now
so you're so fortunate and your portion
because your actions you move quick you
will right so you've done the right
things to deserve this don't let it go
away
[Music]